bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et la
première biographie d'Elizabeth borne
bonsoir Bérengère Bonte bonsoir merci
d'être là la secrète aux éditions de
l'archipel c'est le livre politique dont
tout le monde parle déjà en rupture de
stock en librairie un livre qui vous
vaut une assignation justice de la
première ministre ce qui a pu surprendre
on va en parler tout à l'heure c'est
secret son père ses exigences aussi elle
fait aujourd'hui la première ministre
c'est un an à Matignon on en parle
ensemble dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission mais on va commencer ce
soir par les classes moyennes c'est la
principale annonce du président de la
République hier soir 2 milliards d'euros
pour baisser les impôts de ceux qui
gagnent entre 1500 et 2500 euros par
mois mais il reste pas mal de flou quand
est-ce que ça va se produire ces baisses
d'impôts comment et en a-t-on vraiment
les moyens réforme d'ampleur ou simple
diversion grand débat avec nos invités
dans un instant sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver à 20h15 les affranchis pour
leur partie prix et puis dans Bourbon
Express ce soir retraite comment la
majorité veut empêcher le vote sur
l'abrogation des 64 ans le 8 juin
prochain voilà pour le menu vous me
suivez Bérengère avec plaisir
[Musique]
elle gagne trop pour être aidé mais pas
assez pour finir leur fin de mois les
classes moyennes nouvelles priorité du
président et nouvelle promesse baissée
massivement leurs impôts mais de quoi
parle-t-on précisément et en a-t-on les
moyens bonsoir violette spielbou bonsoir
et merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance du Nord porte-parole du
groupe majorité présidentielle ici à
l'Assemblée vous débattez ce soir avec
Sophie Tellier polluant bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes députés de génération à
l'Assemblée nationale députée du
Val-de-Marne et vice-président du groupe
écologiste à l'Assemblée bonsoir Kevin
ma vieux bienvenue vous êtes député
rassemblement national de l'Eure enfin
Mathieu plane bonsoir et bienvenue ravi
de vous retrouver vous êtes économiste
et directeur adjoint adjoint de l'OFCE
Bérengère bond les classes moyennes
vieilles expression en politique on en
parle depuis des lustres n'hésitez pas
si vous le souhaitez réagir ou tout
simplement interroger nos invités alors
qu'est-ce qu'il a promis précisément
Emmanuel Macron il a deux secondes l'ami
Blacko
bonsoir Stéphane d'akowski bonsoir
madame en Kawa bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors
vous entendez le tic tac ou pas mais oui
le compte à rebours est enclenché il
avait promis 100 jours pour tourner la
page retraite on en est au jour 56
aujourd'hui et au cinquantième jour hier
le président nous a promis deux
milliards de réduction d'impôts alors
attention avant de vous emballer c'est
pas pour tout le monde c'est uniquement
pour les classes moyennes donc le truc
c'est que on a tous un peu l'impression
d'être vaguement un Français moyen et du
coup il a un peu précisé à quel type de
français il s'adressait en écoute le
président
les Françaises et les Français qui
travaillent dur qui veulent bien élever
leurs enfants et qui aujourd'hui parce
que le coût de la vie a monté parce que
la dynamique des salaires est pas
toujours là ont du mal à boucler la fin
du mois mais il faut que eux on les aide
en concentrant ces 2 milliards de baisse
d'impôts sur ces françaises et ses
français donc si vous travaillez dur si
vous vous saignez au 80 pour vos enfants
et que pourtant à la fin du mois vous
avez du mal à joindre les deux bouts ça
y est bienvenue vous êtes dans la classe
moyenne cela dit le président a quand
même un peu précisé d'abord donner des
chiffres c'était dans l'interview qu'il
a donné à l'opinion que d'interview en
ce moment les chiffres c'est qu'entre
1500 et 2500 euros mais au-delà il a
manière un peu plus large définie la
classe moyenne en disant qu'il parlait
de ceux qui sont trop riches pour être
aidés et pas assez riche pour bien vivre
vous rappelle rien mais si mes souvenirs
l'an dernier quand il faisait campagne
pour Pécresse on écoute
c'est français qui sont trop riches pour
être aidés pas assez pour s'en sortir la
France des classes moyennes elle est
représentée ici dans le projet de
Valérie Pécresse
[Applaudissements]
le Président il avait déjà fait pour les
retraites puis ça avait moyen marché on
va dire soyons pas trop injuste
reconnaissons que dès 2019 le président
Emmanuel Macron avait déjà
pris des mesures d'allègement fiscaux
pour les classes moyennes ça c'était il
y a 4 ans voyons on pourrait publier ça
aujourd'hui et pourtant il continue
dans cette voie exactement il continue
dans cette voie donc il y a eu la liste
20 milliards d'impôts qui ont coûté au
budget ça c'était pour la taxe
d'habitation ça a coûté 4 milliards pour
le barème de l'impôt sur le revenu qui a
été revu 3 milliards pour la redevance
bon vraiment c'est des choses qui goûte
assez cher au budget le problème c'est
que on attend ça vite l'oublier on en a
tous profité enfin toute la classe
moyenne mais regardez seulement c'est
ceux qui sont en jaune là seulement 28%
des Français ont le sentiment que les
impôts ont baissé alors c'est un peu
décourageant pourtant le Président il
continue à creuser son citoyen un truc
qu'il a répété depuis le début de son
mandat de ces ils croient dans la valeur
travail il faut travailler plus donc la
gauche elle a plutôt l'air de croire que
quand les gens travaillent dur ils en
veulent aux riches qui se gonfre de
super profits mais il y a un autre
aspect un autre sentiment d'injustice
peut-être qui fait que regarder quand on
demande aux Français sur quoi on
pourrait économiser bah vous voyez il
pense que ça serait pour être les
allocations familiales ou les
allocations chômage donc il y a un
sentiment dans l'idée que Ben certains
profitent des allocations pour ne rien
faire alors que d'autres travaillent dur
en tout cas c'est un sentiment que le
président semble avoir entendu on
l'écoute beaucoup de travailleurs disent
vous nous demandez des efforts il y a
des gens qui travaillent jamais ils ont
quasiment la même vie eux ils vont
jamais travailler ils auront le minimum
vieillesse
oui comme quoi c'est paradoxal on avait
cru comprendre que pendant la réforme
des retraites les Français voulaient
surtout pas travailler plus d'ailleurs
la nuit pêche c'était un peu enflammée
sur cette idée avec Sandrine Rousseau
qui disait le travail c'est un truc de
droite à gauche nous on est pour la
paresse et ben alors vous êtes là pour
en débattre mais moi je pense que au
niveau des classes moyennes je suis pas
sûr que l'appareil soit une vraie valeur
en revanche de travail oui peut-être
c'est possible merci Stéphane alors on y
va sur déjà pourquoi maintenant vu la
suite c'est vrai qu'on peut s'étonner il
y a quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent à trouver vous voulez financer
les services publics l'hôpital l'école
pourquoi un cadeau fiscal maintenant ah
bah parce que c'est une vraie nécessité
qu'on a tous constaté sur le terrain on
est à presque un an de mandat pour les
députés qui ont été élus dans cette
nouvelle mandature avec le gouvernement
Emmanuel Macron nous a demandé d'être
beaucoup sur le terrain on y est
beaucoup on est dans nos
circonscriptions on est on fait des
permanences et c'est vrai qu'on entend
beaucoup cette plainte des français
qu'on soit chauffeur de taxi le travail
dans un hôpital qu'on soit retraité avec
une petite retraite on a l'impression et
c'est finalement pas une impression que
certaines familles ont beaucoup d'aides
des aides au logement des aides
familiales des soins gratuits en
fonction de leurs revenus très bas ce
qui est la justice sociale mais que elle
ces familles qui travaillent qui ont une
personne qui travaille ou des familles
monoparentales et bien parce que elle
dépasse un petit peu le plafond elles
n'ont pas le droit à cette aide donc
c'est vrai que baisser les impôts sur
les classes moyennes on a commencé à le
faire déjà depuis 2019 vous y êtes
revenu la taxe d'habitation les 760
euros en moyenne de moins pour les
effets qu'on a vu vite oublier il y a un
problème de perception je pense que tout
le monde va le voir parce que tous les
foyers français en 2023 sont concernés
plus personne ne paye la taxe
d'habitation c'était progressive donc on
en parlait encore là ça sera
complètement disparu en 2023 la
redevance audiovisuelle aussi ou encore
quelque chose qu'on a voté ensemble avec
l'ensemble des députés pendant le budget
en des années 2022 c'est le fait
d'augmenter le plafond de crédit d'impôt
à 3500 euros pour les gardes d'enfants
ben ça ça bénéficie d'abord au
classement moyenne il y a déjà deux
millions de foyers qui en bénéficient et
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on a
commencé mais c'est vrai que parfois on
peut se dire on vote tout ça et puis les
français payent moins d'impôts et c'est
pas donc vous allez le faire on va voir
quand parce que c'est vraiment très flou
pour l'instant les les contours concrets
de la mesure Kevin mauvieux les classes
moyennes alors ça ça doit vous parler
c'est une partie de votre électorat sur
le bien fondé de de ce cadeau fiscal de
baisser davantage les les impôts de ces
personnes là 1500 2500 vous ne pouvez
pas vous opposer à ça mais on va pas
s'opposer à ce qui va venir aider et
soutenir les classes moyennes on a
toujours dit que les classes moyennes en
France étaient les grandes oubliées ça
fait 6 ans qu'Emmanuel Macron est au
gouvernement on a eu à plusieurs
reprises une forme de matraquage sur les
classes moyennes et une forme aussi
d'aide alors il s'agit de justice
sociale évidemment mais ce qu'il a dit
même s'il ne le pense pas et j'en suis
certain il y a un fond de vrai c'est que
les gens quand on les voit nous disent
régulièrement moi je travaille dur et à
la fin du mois j'ai l'impression de
vivre de la même manière voire moins
bien que mon voisin qui ne travaille pas
et ça c'est enfin baisser les impôts des
classes moyennes plutôt que réduire les
aides sociales de ceux qui
voilà sont pas forcément légitimement en
avoir c'est c'est un bon raisonnement
pour vous bah c'est un bon raisonnement
c'est un bon début en tout cas après
c'est un débat qu'il faut poser qui
qu'il faut poser et sur lequel il faut
travailler mais c'est un bon début
d'aller aider les classes moyennes vous
attendez de voir la copie évidemment
mais sur le principe on va la copie mais
la copie je pense qu'on va attendre
longtemps parce que il faut pas être né
de la dernière pluie pour bien
comprendre qu'en ce moment il y a une
grande contestation sur la réforme des
retraites que le gouvernement patine et
rame on peut utiliser tous les termes
qu'on a envie d'employer pour sortir de
ce débat là et pour essayer de faire
oublier cette réforme voilà l'annonce
des 2 milliards l'objectif c'est de dire
on va
et on le paye comment on s'attaquant
encore une fois au classe moyenne on va
voir et ça c'est compliqué
les gilets jaunes c'est un petit peu ce
qui disait en 2018 classe moyenne on
travaille
ras-le-bol fiscal on s'en sort plus
est-ce que vous voyez un problème précis
dans le pays vous dites simplement
diversion il veut tourner la page des
retraites et tout
que le gouvernement et le président de
la République soit dans l'ornière et
cherche donc des solutions pour
reconquérir un peu de son électorat
c'est sûr donc là il lâche un demi-heure
qu'il n'était pas prévu puisque dans le
programme de stabilité transmis il y a
quelques semaines il y avait peut-être
pas question de donc on ne sait pas
comment les financer on ne sait pas pour
qui on ne sait pas pourquoi il lâche et
je moi je trouve que c'est que c'est
quand même ça démontre à quel point
effectivement ce gouvernement ce
président sont isolés et cherchent des
portes de sortie et il lâche
légitimement pour la population
française
je pense que ce que vous disiez en
parlant des gilets jaunes effectivement
cela renvoie à quelque chose de très
fort dans le mouvement des gilets jaunes
que moi je ne nomme pas le ras-le-bol
fiscal que je nomme le ras-le-bol de
l'injustice fiscale c'est à dire de voir
qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays le poids
du financement du bien commun des
services publics etc est très
inégalement répartie et que et bien ceux
qui sont les plus aisés dans notre
société ils payent beaucoup moins
relativement à ce qu'ils ont que les
ceux qui sont moins aisés donc moi je ne
suis pas défavorable à ce que dans le
cas d'une grande réforme fiscale
évidemment les classes moyennes et les
classes populaires en général paye moins
mais il ne faudrait pas grande réforme
fiscale nous avons progressive et nous
avons
tout dans le cadre de du comment
dirais-je du programme de la nupet sur
une réforme fiscale importante notamment
sur l'impôt sur les revenus pour qu'elle
soit pour qu'il soit plus progressif et
donc pour que certains payent moins et
d'autres payent davantage mais ce qu'il
ne faudrait pas mais pas comme ça ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas c'est qu'on
continue le désarmement fiscal de l'État
c'est à dire petit à petit on baisse
tous les impôts tous les impôts mais qui
est-ce qui paye à la fin ce sont ceux
qui ont besoin du service public donc ce
sont les classes moyennes et les classes
populaires et moi j'en ai un peu assez
qu'on oppose les classes populaires et
les classes moyennes en ne sachant pas
vraiment de quoi on parle parce que ces
personnes là en fait ce sont les
Françaises et les Français ils ont
besoin ils tiennent à leur service
public la situation de l'hôpital la
situation de l'éducation nécessite
nécessite de ressources pour l'État donc
qu'on baisse pour les classes moyennes
pourquoi pas plutôt oui mais à ce moment
là qu'on augmente en face les plus
aisées qui ont on le sait eu nombre de
cadeaux fiscaux et qu'on exige davantage
des entreprises sur le plan social et
environnemental au lieu de les aider
vous savez les entreprises c'est 160
milliards d'euros chaque année donc il y
a effectivement de quoi faire Mathieu
plein je voudrais votre analyse
économique de la mesure mais là-dessus
juste pour répondre à Sophie Tellier
polluant oui pourquoi pas mais dans le
cadre d'une réforme fiscale globale avec
de la justice fiscale notamment par une
contribution plus importante des plus
aisées vous dites quoi je crois que ça a
déjà bien commencé dans le quinquennat
précédent par exemple en baie cent très
fortement l'impôt sur le revenu des deux
premiers niveaux de d'impôts pour les
derniers et donc la proportion c'est
bien écartée en indexant aussi les
impôts sur le revenu et sur leur
évolution donc tout ça c'est des choses
qui vont dans le sens de la justice
fiscale et puis globalement quand on se
préoccupe des classes moyennes c'est
l'ensemble des classes moyennes ça veut
dire augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat on
parle de baisse d'impôt mais quand on a
par exemple un engagement que chaque
nouveau professeur qui rentre dans
l'éducation nationale aura un salaire à
2000 euros et bien on est bien dans le
sujet des classes moyennes et les
engagements salariaux aujourd'hui dans
la fonction publique le rehaussement des
salaires à l'hôpital aussi 280 euros par
mois pour tous les soignants mais tout
ça c'est des choses qui vont dans le
sens d'avoir plus de presse et la
question des financements mais on va
regarder précisément le sujet parce que
on a préparé un sujet sur cette question
de où trouver l'argent votre regard
économiste on est face à une mesure de
politique économique dans un contexte
particulier où c'est de la politique
policière il y a une mesure qui annoncée
donc il y a quand même quelque chose de
concret après c'est vrai que il faut
remettre un peu les choses dans l'ordre
ça arrive après cette réforme des
retraites qui a été difficile à un
moment on a un choc inflationniste qui
est important avec l'énergie plus
alimentaire qui va concerner en priorité
d'ailleurs les classes moyennes parce
que effectivement les salons
qui ont des enfants également c'est
aussi les salaires ne demandent pas
forcément comme les prix alors que par
exemple les prestations sociales les
retraites ont augmenté comme l'inflation
donc c'est vrai qu'elles sont en
première ligne sur ce choc
inflationniste
et du coup il y a cette mesure là mais
on voit bien que les marges de manœuvre
budgétaires sont extrêmement réduites
que Fitch a dégradé la note française
que le gouvernement s'est engagé à
rétablir les finances publiques et
revenir à moins de 3% d'ici 2025 donc il
y a une mesure mais avec des capacités
budgétaires très limitées et qui va
toucher beaucoup de monde mais c'est
beaucoup de monde donc à la fin
c'est-à-dire il reste pas forcément
grand chose et
1500 2500 euros par mois net ce serait
20 millions de Français donc 2 milliards
divisés par 8 millions les ménages mais
si on prend des salariés ça fait un peu
moins oui c'est ça se fait 100 euros par
an donc entre 100 et 200 euros ça dépend
si on prend mon avis dans le discours
c'était quand même plutôt les salariés
qui étaient ciblés hein c'est pas
forcément les retraités il parlait de
ceux qui travaillaient entre 1500 et
2500 euros il y a 60% en gros des
salariés qui sont concernés après est-ce
que par exemple c'est uniquement le
privé ou est-ce qu'il y a également le
public qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
indépendants et quels sont les leviers
fiscaux pour redistribuer du poids
d'achat ces personnes là parce qu'il y a
toute la technicité derrière qu'on a pas
Charles de baisse d'impôt pour les
classes moyennes est-ce que ça veut dire
au fond qu'il ne fait plus confiance aux
entreprises
ça elle prend le relais de d'une hausse
de salaire qui n'arrive pas alors je
pense qu'il y a d'abord il y a un
message politique en disant je
m'intéresse à vous vous sous êtes en
souffrance et donc je prends une mesure
mais c'est vrai qu'il appelle pas à un
geste fort du côté des entreprises en
disant il faut augmenter plus les
salaires pour des questions aussi de
compétitivité donc c'est vrai que
finalement il a écrit les impôts des
classes moyennes ça peut encore plus
freiner la hausse des salades
d'entreprises qui se disent bon ben j'ai
pas j'ai plus rien à faire négocier
votre salaire parce que il y a 2
milliards de baisse d'impôts pour 20
millions 15 millions de personnes donc
non mais c'est des leviers il y a un
message politique assez fort en disant
voilà effectivement il y a un moment
mais derrière dans tout le discours je
crois pas qu'il y a une petite ce qui
disait effectivement le poids de la
fiscalité pèse trop sur les classes
moyennes mais derrière je crois pas
qu'on soit dans une réforme fiscale en
fait je crois qu'on soit dans une baisse
d'impôts avec un signal envoyé sachant
qu'il y a cette contrainte budgétaire
qui joue et que donc du coup il faut pas
s'attendre à quelque chose
d'extraordinaire je crois alors pas
quelque chose d'extraordinaire en
attendant il y a beaucoup de questions
la grosse question c'est de trouver
l'argent comment financer ces deux
milliards de baisse d'impôts quand on
sait déjà l'alerte rouge sur les
finances publiques les mesures
s'appliqueront quand la trajectoire
financière le permettra voilà ce qu'a
dit mot pour mot le Président hier soir
décryptages Marion Becker
pour le moment rien n'est acté ni sur la
forme de la ristourne ni sur le
calendrier seul certitude la France doit
rester dans sa trajectoire budgétaire
pour passer sous les trois pourcents de
déficits d'ici la fin du quinquennat
l'annonce d'Emmanuel Macron intervient
alors que la Cour des comptes et la
Banque de France avait pourtant alerté
sur les risques de nouvelles mesures non
financées arrêtons peut-être un peu la
course à la baisse d'impôts dans ce pays
surtout avec les déficit que nous avons
si on baisse des impôts on ne peut plus
le faire de manière non financée elles
doivent être compensées compensées par
soit des hausses équivalentes soit par
des baisses équivalentes soit par un mix
T2 mais on peut pas se permettre de
créer de nouvelles sources de déficites
à travers cela je pense ce ne serait pas
un bon signal mais comment compenser ces
2 milliards de baisse d'impôts le
gouvernement assure qu'il a la solution
on va faire des propositions avec Bruno
Le Maire sur des économies qui va faire
des
la première ministre a demandé à tous
les ministères d'identifier 5% de marge
de manœuvre dans leur budget on puisse
identifier des économies personne ne
doit échapper à cet effort de 5% sur son
budget pour garantir des financements
notamment de la transition écologique
cela permettra de dégager 7 milliards
d'euros de marge de manœuvre pour les
investissements écologiques ou pour la
réduction de nos dépenses ces marges
seront elles suffisantes cette baisse
des impôts est annoncée 15 jours après
que l'agence Fitch a dégradé la note de
crédit de la France d'un cran en raison
de déficit de budgétaires importants et
de progrès modestes sur leur réduction
pas sûr que cette nouvelle mesure
rassure les agences de notation
alors pile vous donner nous des
éclaircissements où est-ce que vous
trouvez l'argent ou est-ce que vous
compensez c'est de milliards de baisse
d'impôts précisément ce sujet est bien
fait il redit finalement que on a la
responsabilité quand on est la majorité
présidentielle de gérer le budget de la
France la planification budgétaire nous
on a déjà fait un premier exercice en
fin d'année 2022 on va avoir un deuxième
exercice budgétaire qui va commencer
très tôt en septembre
en fait quand on quand on a une nouvelle
dépense comme celle-là il faut qu'elle
soit compensée ça veut dire que on a
bien compris ça veut dire que par
exemple certains crédits d'impôts sur
des choses liées au patrimoine au
capital pourraient par exemple
moi je ne prends pas d'engagement
aujourd'hui au nom de l'ensemble de mes
collègues et encore moins au nom du
Président de la République ce que je
veux dire c'est que trouver l'argent
et que l'on pourrait suivre au prochain
budget il y a aussi bien sûr les
économies globalement sur le train de
vie entre guillemets de nos ministères
la performance de l'organisation de la
fonction publique on était ce midi avec
Stanislas Guérini on a beaucoup parlé de
l'organisation des services des
économies de dépenses donc il y a des
efforts qui ont été demandés à chacun
des ministères parce que on doit
financer des investissements et puis
globalement vous savez 2 milliards
d'euros pour bénéficier à 20 millions de
Français vous l'avez dit moi ça me
semble tout à fait raisonnable quand en
parallèle on a les oppositions qui
proposent la semaine dernière sur la
nationalisation de EDF 11 milliards
d'euros qui sait pas tant que ça ou la
semaine vous ne le ferez que lorsque
vous reviendrez à l'équilibre c'est pas
pour tout de suite voilà je pense que
c'est une question de proportion voilà
c'est pas urgent c'est à dire
dans l'année dans l'année 2023 c'est un
équilibre budgétaire à trouver sauf que
moi j'ai entendu le président de la
République qui dit si la stratégie
budgétaire si la trajectoire budgétaire
pardon le permet enfin je veux dire
c'est très clair or la trajectoire
budgétaire
d'ici la fin vu l'état des finances
publiques vu les notations
de 15 juin
ça ça pose énormément de questions et
enfin je
vous entendre là-dessus mais moi je
voulais aussi savoir sur les vins quand
on dit quand on dit 20 millions de de
français il y en a une grande partie qui
ne paye pas d'impôts donc je veux dire
là on dit on fait miroiter une baisse et
encore une fois ça va dépendre est-ce
que on est sur des impôts sur les
revenus est-ce qu'on est sur une baisse
de cotisation etc mais il faut aussi
dire clairement le ça quoi Mathieu plane
sur les 20 millions effectivement c'est
si on se concentre sur l'impôt sur le
revenu parce que après les gens payent
la TVA des cotisations donc c'est
l'impôt sur le revenu donc le revenu et
pas forcément le bon levier pour
redistribuer du portage en classe
moyenne parce qu'il y a je crois 57% des
fois fiscaux qui ne payent pas d'impôt
sur nous donc une partie de la classe
moyenne du bas de la classe moyenne et
puis effectivement on pouvait pas
distinguer ce qui va être des revenus
liés aux après des liée à ceux du
travail et donc je pense pas que ce sera
l'outil forcément qui sera utilisé donc
y compris le Président il a dit revenu
quotidien
extrêmement difficile de cibler comme ça
une catégorie de population qui
travaille et visait à redistribuer avec
un outil fiscal qui n'est pas forcément
adapté Sophie alors si c'est des
cotisations ça va être la même rengaine
que d'habitude c'est à dire qu'on va
rendre d'un côté et puis reprendre de
l'autre puisque après on nous dit ah là
là c'est les déficits de la Sécurité
sociale du régime des retraites de je
sais pas quoi etc il faut que vous
travaillez deux ans de plus donc un
moment donné les marchés dupe ça va
par ailleurs je vous ai quand même dire
que là aujourd'hui dans ce qui est posé
par le gouvernement envoyé à Bruxelles
sur la trajectoire des finances
publiques il y a déjà une trajectoire
qui est au vu de la politique fiscale je
le répète parce que à force de baisser
les impôts et de distribuer aux
entreprises sans aucune contrepartie on
désarme l'État le terme n'est pas de moi
c'est la Cour des comptes etc qu'est-ce
qui se passe on prévoit une augmentation
des dépenses de l'État de uniquement
zéro 6% or si je disais c'est un peu
technique mais on n'a jamais réussi à
faire ça même les gouvernements les plus
austérités
mais ce sera peut-être le cas mais ça va
être terrible quand je parlais des
services publics tout à l'heure s'il y a
bien des choses sur lesquelles les
classes moyennes peuvent encore
s'appuyer encore dans notre pays et pour
combien de temps ce sont les services
publics c'est l'hôpital c'est l'école
enfin c'est les collectivités locales
on va encore réduire on va encore
réduire les dotations globales des
collectivités comment on va faire garder
nos enfants dans les centres de loisirs
les piscines des bibliothèques c'est ça
aujourd'hui qui se passe c'est que
est-ce qu'on va le financer sur une
nouvelle baisse des services publics
nouvelle saignée dans les services
publics comment vous répondez à ça je
réponds d'abord que on a quelqu'un qui
fait partie de la Nupe ce qui s'est
exprime aujourd'hui et qui avait pour
leader Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans un
programme présidentiel dont il a été
démontré très largement qu'il était
totalement un finançable et qui avait
plus de 100 millions de déficits chaque
année dans le groupe parce qu'ils sont
plus dépensés que vous pouvez là je veux
dire c'est que en fait il n'y a pas de
crédibilité sur une alternative que ce
soit à la France insoumise à l'anus
Emmanuel Macron hérite d'une situation
et réduit les impôts sur les classes
moyennes depuis un quinquennat il
continue aujourd'hui en même temps je
vous donne la parole et je rappellerai
simplement que pendant tous les débats
budgétaires moi ce que j'ai entendu
c'est des oppositions qui rajoutaient
des dépenses de l'État et pas qui en
supprimé et de façon très importante un
milliard d'euros par si un milliard
d'euros par là et donc à chaque fois
juste une question et je vous donne la
parole c'est vrai que sur les dépenses
des des programmes des alternatives de
l'opposition il y avait cette
proposition de Marine Le Pen distribuer
200 euros à tous les ménages français el
y a renoncé parce que c'était beaucoup
trop coûteux c'est toujours sur la table
bah non on s'adapte à la situation et
effectivement vous avez parlé d'héritage
oui on hérite de la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron qui est depuis 6 au pouvoir en
tant que président de la République
depuis plus longtemps parce qu'il a été
ministre sous François Hollande donc les
3000 milliards il y en a au moins un bon
tiers c'est pour lui
c'est quand même important de le
rappeler et vous nous avez dit que les
classes moyennes oui il fallait leur
baisser les impôts je vais venir nous
comment on voit les choses alors déjà je
voudrais juste prendre votre défense par
rapport à tout à l'heure parce que ma
collègue de renaissance était en
difficulté pour vous expliquer d'où
viendrait les rassemblement les
économies si si vous avez dit je peux
pas m'engager je peux pas vous dire sur
les recettes c'est normal parce qu'en
réalité comme vous l'avez bien dit cette
mesure elle vient elle verra jamais le
jour parce qu'en réalité la
trajectoire budgétaire ne sera jamais
tenue donc en réalité on
verraliste
et c'est purement pour faire passer le
la pilule entre guillemets de la réforme
des retraites maintenant nous qu'est-ce
qu'on propose tout à l'heure vous
parliez des entreprises à qui Emmanuel
Macron avait demandé d'augmenter les
salaires et puis il y a renoncé vous
parliez de comment est-ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on fait avec l'impôt sur le
revenu une diminution de l'impôt sur le
revenu alors que toutes les classes
moyennes ne payent pas l'impôt sur le
revenu ou est-ce qu'on passe par les
cotisations bah nous on fait un mélange
de tout ça c'est à dire que on a une
mesure qui ne coûte rien parce que ce
n'est pas de l'argent que l'État sort de
son chapeau on propose d'inciter les
entreprises à augmenter de 10 % les
salaires inciter on n'est pas dans un
état communiste on ne décide pas à la
place des entreprises on veut inciter
les entreprises à augmenter de 10% les
salaires pour tous les revenus qui vont
jusqu'à deux fois et demi le SMIC et en
contrepartie sur cette hausse il n'y a
pas de charge de cotisation sur cette
partie là de hausse de revenus c'est pas
de l'argent dépensé c'est un manque à
gagner la différence est quand même
importante et c'est une mesure qui peut
trouver écho dans ma circonscription et
en permanence j'ai aussi reçu du monde
et notamment des représentants
d'entreprises de chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de Confédération des
artisans qui unanimement disent qu'avec
cette mesure là toutes les entreprises
ne pourront pas augmenter de 10% les
salaires mais qu'une grande majorité
électrons ouverte à une augmentation de
10%. donc c'est une politique de données
ordonnance c'est ça on réduit les
cotisations en échange de hausse de
salaire et du les cotisation et puis
après on explique qu'il faut réduire les
prestations sociales on connaît très
bien la chanson et c'est un et c'est une
ligne commune très libérale entre le
rassemblement national et la majorité
actuelle
notre proposition à nous et toutes nos
propositions elles sont financées
contrairement à ce que dit Madame
spielboot c'est absolument extrêmement
clair mais il faut dans notre pays une
réforme fiscale extrêmement profonde
extrêmement profonde qui est comme
moteur la justice fiscale aujourd'hui
les riches sont de plus en plus riches
c'est pas pour rien si le président
Macron a été affublé de cette étiquette
de président des riches et effectivement
ceux qui ont les plus hauts patrimoine
et notamment les patrimoines financiers
ont payé et paye de moins en moins
d'impôts est-ce normal aujourd'hui dans
notre pays les dividendes explosent
aujourd'hui dans notre pays beaucoup
d'entreprises pas les toutes petit pas
les moyennes mais vois les marges
augmentaient au détriment des salaires
donc oui il y a une autre un autre
partage des richesses qui est possible
ça ne se fait pas du tout d'un
claquement de doigts ça doit se faire en
profondeur et c'est cela qui doit
financer les services publics pourquoi
parce qu'il faut maintenant que dans
notre pays chacun participe à hauteur de
ce qu'il peut faire et les entreprises
comme les ménages doivent participer au
service public c'est ce qui fait société
et donc oui notre nos propositions pour
réarmer le service public elle se fait
sur la base d'une réforme fiscale
importante mais de justice pour que les
classes populaires et moyennes payent
moins il y avait chose France hier je
vais pas me faire à la place du
président et vous dirait peut-être
Mathieu plane dites moi si c'est vrai
que si on fait une grande réforme
fiscale plus plus juste ça fait fuir
l'investissement vrai ou faux
faire l'investissement enfin je suis pas
là pour juger les différents programmes
la question c'est c'est comment dans un
contexte contraint parce qu'on sort
quand même aussi deux années de crise il
faut le savoir en crise covid qui
exceptionnelle une crise énergétique
avec des dépenses qui sont aussi
exceptionnelles qui se traduisent par
une dette et un déficit public plus
élevé et on voit bien sûr que
aujourd'hui le niveau de vie est en
train d'avoir une dynamique qui peut
favorable avec l'inflation or
effectivement c'est un peu leur décompte
aujourd'hui lors des comptes ça veut
dire quoi c'est que on voit que la
contrainte budgétaire est en train de
revenir que les taux d'intérêt remontent
et que les marges de manœuvre se
réunissent sauf que la situation sociale
est pas très bonne et même on voit
qu'une partie de la population perd on
pourra l'achat donc le gouvernement se
retrouve dans cette difficulté c'est de
dire en fait il faudrait redonner la
dynamique de pouvoir d'achat mais on n'a
pas les marges manœuvres et on va
financer par des réductions dépenses
publiques mais on sait bien qu'il y a
pas de réduction magique non plus
dépenses publiques et qu'une partie de
la classe moyenne en fait
bénéficie en réalité dans la
redistribution c'est l'éducation de la
santé et en partie du logement qui sont
des gros postes et aujourd'hui il y a eu
plutôt effectivement il y a aussi ce
côté est-ce que ces services publics une
crise de logement face au taux d'intérêt
et la santé etc donc on voit qu'on a un
problème qui est quand même majeur et
qui va être difficile parce que d'ici
l'horizon 2027 quand vous regardez la
croissance le fait que le gouvernement
s'est contredire on augmentera pas les
impôts y compris sur les plus aisés ou
sur l'épargne etc effectivement la
question c'est où est-ce que vous
trouvez des ressources pour financer non
parce que
la vraie réponse vous avez parlé de
tchus France c'est le travail c'est que
on voit qu'en abaissant énormément le
taux de chômage qui a été réussi et qui
continue de se poursuivre avec beaucoup
d'entreprises et de nouveaux emplois qui
se créent aujourd'hui en France et bien
on augmente en fait la richesse les
recettes et donc c'est l'autre partie
c'est cette politique politique positive
sur le travail qui fait que oui on
baisse les impôts sur le revenu et
pourtant le montant total collecté
d'impôts augmente ça ça veut dire que la
croissance l'activité économique c'est
de la création de l'emploi c'est des
classes moyennes aussi des emplois de
toute nature qui sont créés comme la
semaine dernière les annonces qui ont
été faites à Dunkerque où j'étais aux
côtés du Président de la République et
où on va voir 3000 emplois dans le
domaine des giga Factory de la suivent
écologique et bien tout ça c'est aussi
des actions c'est que le début d'une
réflexion si je vous suis bien il y aura
un budget il y aura des mesures fiscales
dès le budget prochain parce que vous
avez parlé de l'année prochaine si je
vous entends c'est déjà
enterré on va suivre ça on s'arrête là
vous voulez un petit mot pour terminer
très rapidement non juste pour dire que
aujourd'hui on entend beaucoup le
gouvernement se féliciter de la
situation au regard de l'emploi moi ce
que j'observe dans ma circonscription
c'est tant étant de gens qui cherchent
un travail et qui ont beau traversé la
rue qui n'en trouve pas ou qui trouve
des
micro-jobs d'une heure de deux heures
avec une pré-emploi précaire de bons
emplois pour reprendre l'expression
présidentielle on s'arrête là c'est un
débat qui commence et on va le suivre
sur LCP merci à vous d'être venu sur ce
plateau vous restez avec moi Bérangère
Bonte dans une dizaine
si on vous invite Béren gerbon c'est
parce que d'Elizabeth borne qui fait
aujourd'hui même son premier
anniversaire à Matignon on ne sait
finalement que peu de choses une
première ministre austère exigeante
besogneuse finalement qui se cache
derrière ce personnage vous avez enquêté
pendant un an sur cette polytechnicienne
plus techno que politique sur celle que
vous appelez la secrète
Bérengère Bonte journaliste réalisatrice
auteur ce n'est pas la première fois que
vous écrivez sur les locataires de
l'Élysée ou Matignon la secrète donc
tient sans doute cette retenue de son
histoire familiale tragique qu'elle a
tue pendant des décennies
un père juif déportait à Auschwitz qui
se suicide quand elle n'a que 11 ans
c'est finalement pendant son discours de
politique générale la gorge serrée et
reprenant son souffle qu'elle se lance
je suis
première ministre de la France je le
dois à la République
c'est elle qui m'a tendu la main en me
faisant pupille de la nation alors que
j'étais cet enfant dont le père n'était
jamais vraiment revenu des camps
un CV à faire pâlir d'envie première
femme préfète de Poitou-Charentes
présidente de la RATP 3 fois ministre
avant de décrocher Matignon et le record
de longévité pour une femme pour en
arriver là vous décrivez une
personnalité exigeante avec elle-même
mais avec les autres aussi
la secrète inflige une pression
déraisonnable à son entourage borne
engueule tout le monde les directeurs et
sous-directeurs autant que les jeunes
chefs de bureau de 35 ans qui arrivent
aux réunions de cabinets transi de
trouille mais c'est un autre chapitre de
votre livre qui est rythme la couverture
au point de vous assigner en justice et
d'en demander leur retrait la chef du
gouvernement vous reproche d'yvoquer son
orientation sexuelle et sa vie privée
mais vous assumez observez à toutes ces
époques professionnelles depuis son
divorce le mystère de cette femme qui
n'a pas de vie en dehors du boulot
alimente forcément le trouble enfin vous
décrivez une femme intelligente rapide
bugnace et l'on connaît la tentation qui
touche tous les premiers ministres alors
nous avons une question Bérengère Bonte
la secrète qui ne lâche rien a-t-elle un
autre secret celui peut-être de se voir
un jour à l'Élysée
réponse Bérangère Bonte je l'ai posé à
beaucoup de gens je l'évoque dans le
dernier chapitre
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est en train de
construire une officine et de préparer
quelque chose pour ça en revanche c'est
une question qui l'inquiète beaucoup qui
m'a valu moi des coups de fil un peu sur
le tard de Matignon présidentielles
qu'on puisse penser que effectivement
depuis toute petite elle a certaines de
ses amis qui lui disent prochaine étape
c'est l'Élysée des politiques qui me
l'ont dit c'est à dire on sait qu'une
présidentielle c'est ce jour où on dit
toujours la rencontre d'une personne à
un moment avec le peuple etc les
circonstances peuvent faire que encore
une fois n'est pas en train de se
préparer mais de même qu'elle soit
disant n'avait pas fait campagne pour
Matignon ce qui est faux là évidemment
que c'est forcément on y pense forcément
et
qu'à d'autres en rêvent à sa place c'est
une enquête extrêmement fouillée je le
disais vous avez rencontré deux fois
Elisabeth borne longuement vous avez vu
tous ses proches et notamment sa soeur
Anne-Marie en quête qui permet d'abord
de comprendre le traumatisme de
l'enfance se perd qui n'est donc jamais
revenu des camps et qui va se défoncer
parce qu'il est revenu mais jamais
totalement vous avez raison préciser et
qui va se suicider dans la maison de
famille même si la famille hésite encore
sur la version maison de Livarot en
Normandie alors que Elisabeth borne n'a
que 11 ans parlez-nous de Joseph
Bornstein devenu Joseph borne à sa
sortie d'Auschwitz c'est un homme qui
qui rentre des camps qui étaient qui
étaient résistants qui a un parcours de
résistant assez assez admirable comme
beaucoup de résistants évidemment c'est
presque une banalité de dire ça mais qui
qui d'ailleurs s'engage dans les réseaux
de résistance
sans trop le dire à son père qui qui
lui-même est à Patrick qui est venu se
réfugier en France avec ses quatre fils
juste après le décès de sa femme et ils
étaient eux en Belgique à ce moment-là
et qui est arrêté une fois qui est
arrêté une deuxième fois qui s'échappe
et qui survit à Auschwitz avec son frère
ils sont partis ils ont été ils ont été
déportés à qui ne sont revenus qu'à deux
lui et son frère voilà on le voit là
et et il sera finalement à partir du de
la naissance de d'Elizabeth borne c'est
une dépression qui va l'amener
progressivement jusqu'à cette issue
fatale et c'est une enfant qui est
évidemment marquée par ce père qui avec
des avec des barreaux aux fenêtres avec
quelques moments de relation mais elle
dit elle-même que son père avait une
relation très forte avec sa sœur et elle
m'a dit mais j'aimais du réécouter
quatre fois le dictaphone et je crois
que ça lui est suffisait il y a voilà
alors
quand c'est un père qui a commencé à la
sortie des camps à parler à témoigner
comme beaucoup d'autres survivants et
qu'on a fait terre ça c'est aussi une
des éléments assez surprenants parce que
beaucoup de déportés n'ont pas n'ont pas
raconté lui il a tout de suite beaucoup
parlé sauf que le curé du village deux
lettres avait été publiées où il
racontait les les chambres à gaz
l'horreur l'horreur de
et le curé du village a dit mais vous
n’importe quoi comment pouvez-vous
inventer ça et de ce jour-là il
s'améliorer dans le silence c'est sa
mère Marguerite qui va d'une manière
particulière être un peu porteuse de
cette histoire alors qu'elle n'est pas
juive non elle catholique et elle va
beaucoup d'ailleurs travailler et
jusqu'aux ces derniers jours elle est
décédée à 95 ans donc voilà elle a
beaucoup travaillé sur le rapprochement
des deux des deux cultures et des deux
religions notamment sur la fin de sa vie
où elle va elle va apprendre
l'hébreu le midi c'est ça pour pouvoir
traduire les textes elles-mêmes et
travailler effectivement
enfin c'est quelque chose qui a été très
très fort chez elle et qui était la
suite logique une forme d'hommage
évidemment
à son mari décédé depuis déjà longtemps
et aujourd'hui sa soeur donc l'aînée
Anne-Marie reçoit des informations de
partout sur cette histoire familiale où
elle arrivait l'arrivée d'Elizabeth
borne à Matignon a évidemment
amené pas mal de témoignages de
recherche parfois il y a eu très très
donc très intéressant du Dauphiné Libéré
de nos confrères qui sont allés chercher
dans les archives départementales les
conditions de l'arrestation de la
famille born avec un logeur qui qui les
a dénoncé
qui est dit je crois bien que c'est
bornes ne sont pas tout à fait non pas
tout à fait ce nom là et c'est un prête
non pour cacher des Israélites enfin
tout ces termes abominables et oui c'est
une histoire très très lourde quelle
porte qui est qui est évidemment
douloureuse dont elle a pas réussi à
parler pendant très très longtemps et je
raconte à quel point c'est très étonnant
il y a une journaliste du Nord qui est
venue la voir ils ont fait deux fois un
portrait depuis son entrée à matinion
ils sont fascinés par cette histoire les
Américains et la journaliste du Newton
je lui ai dit mais aux États-Unis vous
auriez fait votre carrière politique
là-dessus et elle moi m'a dit
il ne veut pas où elle ne peut pas c'est
les deux les deux très douloureux mais
elle avait aussi visiblement la crainte
qu'on ne lui reproche d'utiliser ça
alors elle dit très pudiquement que son
environnement était un peu lourd jusqu'à
fuir quand même l'appartement familial à
16 ans oui
c'est une femme libre qui s'est
émancipée quand même comme elle m'a dit
c'est assez étonnant je vers 16 ans à
cette époque là c'est quand même pas non
plus
on est à la fin des années 70 passif
fréquent mais elle trouve ça elle voit
pas où le problème en l'occurrence elle
s'en va c'est lui qui deviendra le père
de son fils donc oui enfin j'ai rien
n'est j'ai sauvé aussi grâce aux
mathématiques alors
elle a une conscience assez claire de ce
qui s'est passé en tout cas puis
progressivement
du suicide au moment où vraiment elle se
retrouve toute seule le monde s'écroule
et elle se dit il y a qu'un truc qui
tient dans la vie c'est les maths les
maths c'est un ou zéro et donc elle
s'est effectivement enfermée là dedans
un peu coupé de ses émotions il faut
bien le dire je veux dire tous les
témoignages des différentes époques de
sa vie toutes les époques
professionnelles
rapportent ça d'une façon ou d'une autre
alors polytechnicienne en 1981 elle
devient ingénieur des Ponts elle
commence une carrière politique d'abord
comme au fonctionnelle puis elle devient
conseillère et équipement éducation Jack
Lang Lionel Jospin préfet en
Poitou-Charentes elle devient pas trop
de la SNCF puis de la RATP c'est une
femme de gauche quelles sont ses
convictions alors moi j'ai toujours du
mal à la dire de gauche je elle m'a
marié Dracul me dit même bien sûr que
non on l'a jamais été de gauche Aurélien
Rousseau son directeur de cabinet me dit
mais si mais dans les premiers nos
premiers échanges sur le travail sur la
valeur du travail j'ai vu la femme de
gauche moi je pense j'irais pas
quelqu'un qui a une charpente politique
et une culture politique elle a pas
bibronnée aux biographies de Bloom et de
menders France de Jean la couture c'est
on n'est pas là-dedans en revanche qui
est un fond de valeur très fort oui de
solidarité évidemment liée à la
situation dans laquelle c'est retrouver
sa maman ça c'est une chose sachant que
les entreprises familiales avaient fait
faillite et puis c'est des rencontres en
fait c'est surtout des rencontres alors
celle de son futur mari par exemple et
puis celle de Lionel Jospin à qui elle a
adhéré comme homme il avait la même
rigueur la même austérité aussi
austérité rigueur elle travaillait
énormément à s'en faire mal parfois très
important et certains parfois me disent
mais mais tous les politiques
travaillent non madame pardon mais non
je veux dire ça fait du pour le coup ça
fait du bien de c'est une pure ingénieur
quelqu'un qui est ce son précise qui
déroutent beaucoup je pense à la classe
politique ça lui vaut des des
qualificatifs de techno alors ça
supporte de façon très péjorative le
procès supportant des connexions du
terrain elle supporte pas c'est une
vraie politique vous diriez quand elle
dit par exemple j'utiliserai plus 49,3
elle a un sens politique vraiment elle a
elle a elle a un sens politique au sens
par exemple la période de de
Poitou-Charentes elle se retrouve elle
se retrouve très faite
franchement
alors qu'elle avait fait des cabinets à
la mairie de Paris à l'urbanisme chez
les nageuses peints à Matignon vous vous
retrouvez préfet vous devez quand même
sacrément faire en sorte que tous ces
gens se parlent elles elles
tord le bras de Ségolène Royal qui est
présidente de région pour lui faire
mettre la main au pot sur un projet de
Jean-Pierre Raffarin qui sont ennemi
juré enfin elle s'est arrivée à ses fins
politiques c'est une terreur ça on l'a
compris avec ses collaborateurs
absolument aussi je voudrais qu'on en
vienne à la signation en justice et ses
chapitres dont Elisabeth borne demandent
le retrait des chapitres entiers sont
des passages parfois sur des choses
totalement anodines mais mais
effectivement pour le coup ça pour le
coup c'est quand même une vraie surprise
et une source d'inquiétude il faut le
dire franchement qu'une première
ministre en exercice tout d'un coup
demande effectivement à voilà j'espère
que la justice nous rappellera que on a
le droit d'enquêter et d'écrire vous
précisiez pour être vous vous assumez
d'avoir évoqué ces rumeurs concernant
son orientation sexuelle mais moi je
pars de d'éléments qu'elle a soit
elle-même mis sur la table soit c'est
très proche c'est ou soit d'éléments qui
étaient dans le débat les rumeurs
d'homosexualité ne vient pas de moi elle
dément en arrivant
[Musique]
dans têtu qui est quand même donc le
magazine très identifié par la
communauté LGBT donc c'est un sujet qui
est sur la table elle dit elle dément
voilà et elle ajoute mais j'ai un
compagnon qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
faites la bio vous cherchez qui est
cette personne s'il avait eu un profil
totalement entre guillemets anodin s'il
avait été prof de sport
ou boucher charcutier et j'adore la
viande
l'histoire était terminée sauf qu'il a
un profil très politique qui pose
énormément de questions qu'il est il a
été candidat européenne il est très
engagé il est toujours enfin il a été
président d'une association qui appelait
à la manif pour tous
jusqu'à cette île jusqu'à cet hiver elle
l'a embauché à la RATP quand elle était
président autant de questions que j'ai
voulu lui poser une fois que j'ai
vraiment eu la certitude sur cette photo
surtout qui a été publiée par closer
voilà et il se trouve que à la fin de la
fin de la fin de la fin je découvre
qu'en fait depuis deux ans il est passé
avec une autre femme il le dit lui-même
sur son blog donc en fait
elle elle la seule certitude que j'ai
finalement c'est que cet homme n'est pas
son compagnon pourquoi pourquoi mettait
ça sur la table ça posait vrai question
je veux dire honnêtement c'est voilà ça
s'appelle un mensonge d'ailleurs selon
vos sources l'Élysée aurait même trouvé
épatante l'idée qu'une première ministre
fasse son coming out c'est son
anniversaire à Matignon aujourd'hui je
vais vous montrer un tout petit extrait
voilà comment on lui a fêté sur les
bancs de l'hémicycle côté insoumis
en l'espace d'un an vous avez fait de
notre pays une poudrière bravo Madame la
première ministre quel anniversaire le
programme que nous mettons en œuvre
madame la Présidente panneau c'est celui
sur lequel le président de la République
a été élu et définitivement vous ne
mettez pas mais ce n'est pas le Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Emmanuel Macron que les
Français ont choisi et on a pas marre de
la dureté du job elle s'accroche
jusqu'au bout elle veut rester moi je
crois qu'elle va rester je pense que je
vois pas pourquoi elle a pas démérités
je pense que personne d'autre te
trouvera de majorité en l'état donc je
vous explique quel est l'intérêt et elle
dans le contenu de tout ce que je
raconte de toute de sa pugnacité de la
façon dont elle s'accroche dont elle
s'est accrochée dans la période où elle
était directrice de cabinet de Ségolène
Royal notamment sous les yeux d'un
ministre de l'économie qui s'appelait
Emmanuel Macron qui a bien vu à quel
point elle était du roman et capable de
résister oui pour toutes ces raisons je
pense après les circonstances font
peut-être quelques finances
merci beaucoup Bérengère Bérengère bon
qui signe donc la secrète la première
biographie aux éditions de l'archipel
c'est une enquête fouillée passionnante
sur une femme politique à la trajectoire
incroyable il faut le rappeler vous
restez avec moi c'est l'heure des
affranchis leur parti pris vous vous
faire réagir on les accueille tout de
suite
affranchi iOS ce soir au féminin pluriel
bonsoir Fanny Fanny guinochet de France
Info pour l'économie et à chamboncelles
de popol le podcast politique qui nous
parle de la vieillesse au féminin dans
un instant on commence comme chaque soir
par le bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nous est raconté ce
soir par Stéphanie Despierre bonsoir
Stéphanie bonsoir Myriam mais l'histoire
du camp présidentiel qui veut contrer la
proposition de loi pour abroger la
réforme des retraites alors depuis
plusieurs jours Renaissance et ses
alliés réfléchissaient à la stratégie à
adopter face à cette offensive
coordonnée des groupes IOT et de la
nupes ce matin ils ont tranché il
brandissent l'article 40 de la
Constitution un article qui stipule
qu'une loi ou un amendement ne sont pas
recevables s'il crée une charge
financière pour l'État ou s'il diminue
les recettes des finances publiques les
macronistes estiment donc que la
proposition de liotte est
inconstitutionnelle et donc il ne faut
pas en débattre le 8 juin dans
l'hémicycle
si j'accepte cela ça veut dire que
demain n'importe quel groupe déposer un
texte à 100 milliards d'euros à 50
milliards d'euros à 20 milliards d'euros
à 30 milliards d'euros et il y a aucun
moyen de refuser la recevabilité de ce
texte alors que ça engage les deniers de
l'État sans compensation donc ça c'est
un vrai problème juridique
constitutionnel
sauf que c'est la coutume à l'Assemblée
les propositions de loi ne passent pas
au filtre de l'article 40 le bureau de
l'Assemblée a donc validé sans problème
ce texte de liotte mais ce n'est pas
trop tard pour changer d'avis les
groupes macronistes brandissent cette
fois un autre article 89 4 il faut
suivre article non pas de la
Constitution mais du Règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale
s'il n'a pas été exercée à priori que le
dépôt a pu être réalisé rien n'empêche
que ce contrôle soit exercé maintenant
c'est d'ailleurs très clairement écrit
dans notre règlement intérieur c'est
l'article 89-4 de notre règlement
intérieur qui permet à tout député par
un groupe tout député de saisir soit le
président de la commission des finances
ou et c'est bien écrit ou le rapporteur
général de la commission des finances
s'il y a un doute sur la recevabilité
financière d'une disposition d'une
proposition de loi ou d'un amendement
bon on comprend que ce vote n'est pas
bienvenu dans la majorité alors des
cadres au syndrenaissance on fait valoir
leurs arguments ce matin pendant une
réunion hebdomadaire qui réunissait tous
les groupes de la majorité oui Myriam
liotte et la nupes ont dénoncé des
manœuvres et ils y voient un coup de
pression sur la Présidence de
l'Assemblée ce matin il y a LeBron Pivet
a clairement refusé de revenir sur la
décision du bureau elle ne veut pas être
fusible explique en coulisses des
députés du camp présidentiel un autre
député Renaissance est beaucoup plus
sévère il pense il y a LeBron Pivet est
en campagne pour 2027 ses intérêts
personnels passent avant ceux de
l'institution alors devant microsé
caméra c'est sur Éric Coquerel que la
majorité renvoie la responsabilité de
décider si la proposition de loi est
recevable Éric Coquerel qui est le
président de la commission des finances
depuis 2009 notamment il n'y a jamais eu
de demandes d'y recevabilité de toute
une loi porter ainsi que ça soit au
niveau du bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale au niveau d'un président de la
commission des finances c'est absolument
nouveau parce que il est coutume de
penser une certaine jurisprudence que
quelque part l'initiative parlementaire
doit pouvoir respirer alors est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'avant il y avait eu des
lois qui posaient éventuellement un
problème de gage non la différence c'est
que la majorité était majoritaire et que
les questions qui se posent maintenant
c'est que cette majorité a peur de ne
pas refuser pouvoir refuser par le vote
la propulsion de loi qui va être proposé
par les hautes voilà toute la question
et donc politique alors que se
passera-t-il si Eric Coquerel estime que
la loi est recevable ce qui est le plus
probable et bien Renaissance pourrait
faire valoir le point de vue opposé du
rapporteur général du budget qui aura le
dernier mot la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale devra-t-elle pourra-t-elle
voudra-t-elle faire le juge de paix la
bataille d'interprétation juridique
Myriam à coup d'articles de la
Constitution ou de règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale ne fait que ouais
voilà c'était un feuilleton avec
plusieurs épisodes on l'a compris et les
piloques ce sera le 8 juin tout semble
porter à croire que voilà ce vote n'aura
pas lieu on verra on verra ce qu'il en
est Fanny consultation ça y est ça
reprend le dialogue social à Matignon
justement Elisabeth born recevait la
CFDT Force Ouvrière ça se passe ce soir
en ce moment alors les recevoir en
bilatéral comme on dit les uns derrière
les autres c'est malin divisé pour mieux
régner alors c'est la volonté du
gouvernement mais les syndicats eux ont
à cœur de montrer leur unité ils ont
beau défiler les uns après les autres
dans le bureau de la première minute
d'Elizabeth borne ils veulent montrer
qu'ils sont unis toujours contre cette
réforme des retraites et d'ailleurs il
prévoit une manifestation une journée
d'action avec des grèves le 6 juin
prochain tous ensemble ils ont envoyé un
communiqué avant ces rencontres
bilatérales à la première ministre pour
lui dire une fois de plus qu'ils étaient
contre cette réforme mais il y a aussi
un certain nombre de sujets sur lesquels
ils front commun face au gouvernement la
réforme du RSA par exemple le
gouvernement a dit qu'il allait
sanctionner et durcir les conditions des
bénéficiaires du RSA l'assurance chômage
pareil là aussi les syndicats disent on
est tous contre cette idée de
durcissement des conditions des règles
pour les demandeurs d'emploi de la même
façon il demande tous des augmentations
de salaire il demande aussi qu'un
certain nombre d'aides qui sont versées
aux entreprises soit conditionnées à des
objectifs sociaux environnementaux vous
voyez les sujets de convergence en fait
ils sont extrêmement nombreux et ça va
être beaucoup plus difficile que prévu
pour la première ministre de diviser les
syndicats il y a quand même des
différences entre eux oui alors des
petites différences d'appréciation parce
que bien sûr chacun a son unité sa
personnalité syndicale par exemple pour
la CGT augmenter les salaires la
meilleure façon de le faire c'est
d'indexer les salaires sur l'inflation
le reste et du bricolage alors que pour
la CFDT ce qui compte c'est surtout que
les minimas sociaux qui sont en dessous
du SMIC soit voyez c'est sur des petits
points que le gouvernement va essayer de
jouer et le départ de Laurent Berger à
la tête de la CFDT ça peut aider le
gouvernement jouer la division alors
c'est prévu le 21 juin mais là où ça va
être compliqué c'est que en fait il
passe la main Laurent Berger à Marylise
Léon que ce passage de témoin est très
bien préparé que Marylise Léon est dans
la continuité de Laurent Berger et puis
avec Sophie Binet de la CGT qui a
remplacé Philippe Martinez certes les
deux femmes ne se connaissent pas très
bien mais elles sont finalement elles
ont un certain nombre d'atomes crochus
pour pouvoir s'entendre elles sont
toutes les deux des femmes elles sont
très elles ont quasiment le même âge
elles sont très engagées dans les sujets
de lutte contre pour l'égalité
homme-femme pour l'écologie donc elles
peuvent trouver un certain nombre de
terrains d'entente et globalement de
toute façon toutes les organisations
syndicales ont compris après ce conflit
sur les retraites que c'était leur union
qui faisait la force que c'est ce qui
attendait les Français c'est vraiment
qu'il y ait des syndicats qui soient
moins divisé plus en harmonie et donc
ils ont tous encore intérêt à faire
vivre leur inter syndicale longtemps sur
différents sujets ce qui n'est pas
vraiment une bonne nouvelle pour
Elisabeth borne on va suivre ça grâce à
vous Fanny guinochet Elisabeth borne
vous en parlez d'ailleurs grand
négociatrice c'est plutôt Corinthe
intermédiaire contrairement un peu à
Emmanuel Macron on enchaîne parce qu'il
nous reste peu de temps Léa vous dit
nous parler d'un livre ce soir signé
Fiona Schmitt intitulé vieille peau
parce qu'il faut le dire et le redire
c'est difficile de vieillir après 50 ans
et c'est une source d'inégalité entre
les hommes et les femmes absolument
alors on pouvait se dire qu'il y a bien
une chose face à laquelle on est tout et
tous égaux c'est bien la mort d'une part
mais aussi le fait de vieillir mais
alors non figurez-vous qu'effectivement
c'est plus difficile de vieillir en
fonction de notre condition sociale mais
aussi en fonction du travail que l'on
fait mais pas que aussi aux fonctions de
notre genre ça veut dire que les femmes
et les hommes ne vieillissent pas dans
les mêmes conditions et bien pas tout à
fait alors certes les femmes
vieillissent plus longtemps disons que
les femmes ont une espérance de vie de
85 ans contrairement aux hommes qui sont
qui est de 79 ans néanmoins une étude de
l'adresse donc la Direction de la
recherche des études de l'évaluation et
des statistiques qui a été publiées en
2019 nous démontre que certes les femmes
vivent plus longtemps néanmoins elles
vivent dans des conditions de dans des
conditions de
de quoi de vie de vie qui sont qui sont
effectivement plus difficiles notamment
par rapport à leur santé puisque elles
peuvent être en bonne santé a priori
jusqu'à 64 ans et les hommes jusqu'à 63
ans donc certes elles vivent plus
longtemps néanmoins en moins bonne santé
et ce qu'il faut aussi dire c'est que il
faut aussi remarquer qu'il y a bien une
injonction qui pèse sur les femmes qui
n'est pas une injonction qui pèse sur
les hommes c'est celle de ne pas
vieillir ou alors au mieux de vieillir
correctement c'est à dire qu'on va dire
un homme que ce n'est pas très grave
d'avoir des rides ou des cheveux gris en
revanche c'est totalement inaccepté pour
une femme ce que l'on constate aussi et
ce livre nous le démontre c'est que le
vieillissement accentue en fait des
inégalités de genre à travers le temps
donc Fiona Schmidt nous rappelle donc
les femmes sont d'une part discriminées
en raison de leur genre mais pas que
elles sont aussi discriminées en raison
de leur âge c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'agisme la gysisme c'est cette
discrimination sur l'âge et il faut
savoir qu'aussi en France c'est une
réalité puisque quand on regarde la
façon dont sont traités voire maltraités
nos aînés notamment dans les EHPAD comme
la relevé l'enquête de Victor Castanet
sur les maisons de retraite on peut
quand même se poser la question de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on traite nos
vieux et nos vieilles d'un mot pour
terminer justement la dépendance encore
un monde fan encore un monde de femmes
effectivement Fiona Schmitt emploie
cette expression qui est assez
intéressante elle dit que la vieillesse
c'est un monde de femme délégué aux
femmes il faut savoir que oui
pensionnaires sur 10 dans les EHPAD sont
des femmes et que par ailleurs 90% des
professionnels qui travaillent dans les
EHPAD sont des femmes donc ça repose
essentiellement sur les sur les femmes
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il semble assez
important notamment à un moment où on
parle de fin de vie etc de liberté le
gouvernement sur la nécessité d'avoir
une approche genrée en matière de
politique publique sur le vieillissement
et peut-être que les responsables
politiques gagneraient à lire ce livre
de fionachmi Fiona chipit vieille peau
voilà pour le titre c'est vrai qu'on en
parle de plus en plus de ce sujet mais
bon peu encore non mais on peut dire
quand même aussi merci
Bérengère bon de lisez la secrète aux
éditions de l'archipel il y a encore
quelques exemplaires en librairie ils
arrivent il y a duré ça cartonne c'est
un personnage je sais pas j'espère qu'on
la comprend c'est un personnage beaucoup
plus intéressant pardon mais que ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent beaucoup plus
qui a beaucoup plus d'épaisseur me
semble très bien et ben voilà vous
découvrirez merci à vous merci les
affranchis et à très vite quant à moi je
vous retrouve demain même lieu même
heure très belle soirée sur LCP bien sûr
[Musique]